there are people who make a mistake and
admit they made a mistake and they move
as quickly as possible in the direction
of fixing the mistake that they made
there are other people who make a
mistake and they double down either
because their ego won't allow them to
admit defeat or because they genuinely
can't change their mind and consider
that they might have actually done
something wrong Donald Trump is in the
latter camp he doesn't admit to making
mistakes he usually does double down
even on the worst mistakes that he's
made and right now one of the biggest
mistakes the Donald Trump is made in his
still early presidency is the trade war
that he has started and Donald Trump is
doubling down and he's doubling down so
hard on this that he started to make
completely wild and wacky claims with no
connection to reality whatsoever the
reality of the tariffs that Donald Trump
has placed on American allies around the
world is that they're going to hurt
American businesses and also American
workers that's the reality trade Wars
are not good or easy to win despite
Donald Trump saying that they're good
and easy to win the tariffs are gonna
make American products more expensive
around the world that's going to hurt
American businesses it'll hurt workers
the tariffs are going to lead to
retaliatory tariffs from our allies that
will make their products more expensive
for us that's also bad for Americans who
aren't necessarily swimming in extra
money with which to purchase foreign
goods and Donald Trump most recently
this is so whacked out has suggested
that the tariffs might be so good for
the United States that the revenue
created by the tariffs could conceivably
make the federal income tax unnecessary
and this is so silly
that it's hard to know whether it even
warrants a response or if it's just an
example of how disconnected this man is
from reality when a play video for you
Trump is saying that the tariffs could
be so good that it could be like when
McKinley was President of the United
States in the late 19th century what the
hell does Donald Trump know about
William McKinley and that the United
States didn't even need income taxes at
the time because just
tariffs can be so good it is completely
perverted logic but it's sort of what
Donald Trump seems to be applying to
this situation take a look 30 percent
tariffs or so tariffs can be a very
positive thing you know the old days
when we had tariffs we didn't have
income tax when people wanted to come in
you look at the days of McKinley and
some others when people wanted to come
in they had to pay a price when they
want to come in and raid our treasury
they had to pay a price we didn't have
income tax you didn't need income tax we
didn't have debt so we're doing this I
will say in every instance every country
any country that you can mention has
been extremely nice so what he's saying
is in previous times when we had tariffs
and no income taxes things worked really
well so therefore his tariffs now are a
good thing now it's just so you have the
data federal spending as a portion of
the total economy is 10 times higher now
than it was during the McKinley era that
Donald Trump references so as a
comparison this is totally meaningless
this is the type of math that leads to
bankrupt casinos and it is not that
shocking that the guy who thinks trade
wars are good and easy to win and knows
nothing about taxes and has no clue how
to run a government might think that
maybe if you do really well with the
tariffs you wouldn't even really need
the federal income tax
yeah when McKinley was president we
didn't have Social Security we didn't
have Medicare our military wasn't what
it is now yeah it wasn't what 15
government departments and countless
more agencies well careful sustainable
careful because that's the logic they'll
used to say well we got to get rid of
all that stuff
we got a shrink Social Security and
we've got to get rid of a bunch of those
government departments right so you got
to be careful with that logic military
can stay big though military can double
absolutely we need it much bigger
sometimes I listen to this stuff and I
think back to my high school economics
class there were students in my high
school econ class who seemed to have a
better grasp of these big economic
issues and fundamentals than Donald
Trump has and I want to mention the
McKinley thing the fact that Trump
mentioned President William McKinley who
was president starting in 1890s
seven this isn't something Trump is an
expert on if Trump is mentioning William
McKinley it's because somebody told him
mention William McKinley I don't think
anybody at this point believes that
Donald Trump is a casual historian who
knows a lot about President William
McKinley such that he could make this
comparison in this this casual way I
would point to either Stephen Miller or
I don't even know a coke brother or
someone who has Trump seer on this stuff
it's like when Steven Bannon got him
interested in Andrew Jackson exactly man
the comparisons started and didn't
really end this is absolutely ludicrous
it is a gong show a comedy of errors
harebrained idea after harebrained idea
I don't know what analogy or phraseology
you want you want to apply to it but we
are in a period where total ignorance
and saying whatever comes to mind or
whatever somebody said in your ear five
minutes before a camera got turned on is
being accepted as some kind of
truth-telling tough guy
patriotic gospel I I don't even know
what other word to apply to it and it is
stunningly disturbing